prince william and prince harry have
tried to control their own hatred of the
media by trying to control the media the
royal family is not happy about a new
bbc documentary centered on prince harry
and prince william's relationship with
the press i think at the best of times
the palaces are nested vipers after part
one of the dock titled the princes and
press aired buckingham palace kensington
palace and clarence house all released a
joint statement to evening standard
slamming the program quote a free
responsible and open press is of vital
importance to a healthy democracy
however too often it is overblown and
unfounded claims from unnamed sources
that are presented as facts and it is
disappointing when anyone including the
bbc gives them credibility the two-part
doc explores the relationship prince
william and prince harry have with the
media showing how royal sources
allegedly work with journalists
one prince is choosing to play the game
with britain's media
editors from various newspapers have
been invited in to meet him the other
has tried to change the rules of that
game he will
turn away from cameras to deny them a
shot scowl at journalists meanwhile the
bbc is defending their work in a
statement posted on their website the
network states that the doc looked at
the tensions for the two royals between
the benefits of publicity and the
downsides of intrusion and how they
tried to handle the press adding quote
journalists and commentators described
how information was sometimes obtained
whether by leaks or by dishonest
practices such as phone hacking and
whether reputations were managed and
damaged through unofficial briefings
one of those commentators featured in
the doc was royal expert omit scoby
there's been rumor for quite some time
that a lot of the most damaging and
negative stories about harry and meghan
that have ended up in the pages of the
press have come from other royal
households or from other royal aids or
courtiers and from my own reporting and
research that is exactly true
the british journalist has previously
spoken to et about prince harry and his
wife meghan markle's relationship with
the media this was a couple that felt
very misunderstood by sections of the
tabloid press here et chatted with scoby
prior to the release of his book about
the couple finding freedom where he
opened up about megan not fully knowing
what she was getting herself into with
the tabloids as she married into the
royal family which ultimately was one of
the many factors in her and harry's
decision to step back from their royal
duties in 2020. i think there's a
difference between being warned before
marrying someone like prince harry that
your life will change for good that the
press will not leave you alone and to be
reminded of what diana went through uh
particularly during those very difficult
times after her divorce with prince
charles and these are things that megan
would have gone into that marriage
knowing but it's very different to know
it than to live it and i think whilst we
saw megan put on a very brave front
publicly
as the book tells behind the scenes she
really struggled with some of those
intrusions and just to have so many
people involved in her life there's that
scene where she wears a necklace after
she her relationship with harry's out in
the open it's got their initials on it
and she receives a call from someone at
the palace just to really reprimand her
for doing something could be so
attention-seeking now sure that could be
great advice but at the same time when
you're in the real thick of it it's
something that can really be one word
too many and and as we read in the pages
of the book it was an emotional moment
for her one that she struggled to deal
with and i think time and time again
there were new things happening within
that situation that she just wasn't
prepared for i don't think anyone can
prepare you
you